I am not registered to vote I am
registered to vote but I probably will
not be voting this upcoming election the
whole processes and tune dating and
confusing and I just don't really know
where to begin I don't think my votes
gonna make a difference the candidates
that we've had here I haven't been
passionate about any of them it's very
time-consuming there is a huge line
oh wow okay metal detectors there's
serious security at this there's like a
man with a machine gun dip your hand in
purple ink and you pretty much vote with
your fingerprint people are threatening
these women saying if they vote they're
going to come to their houses and attack
them risking your life to go vote I mean
it's pretty brave the ink that they get
on their finger like that's not just
like an I voted sticker that you can
take off it's like gonna be there for
the rest of the day so it makes them a
target for people who are trying to harm
them and that's really scary I had no
idea that it was so dangerous to do
something this simple
it's so exciting to see a lot of people
show up to vote who fought so hard to do
so they were talking about the numbers
of how many african-americans versus how
many white people had gone to the polls
to vote and they said 80% of the people
in that area had gone who are
african-american so that is incredible
considering how there's so many of us
today who say I'm not voting Wow some of
the men talking in this oh my god so
these women aren't allowed to leave the
house without a male chaperone oh well
if she leaves the house to go vote who's
gonna take care of the children how long
is it gonna take for her to leave the
house and go vote sit down at least our
standing up for something that they
believe in these women are still going
out and voting even though there's still
so many borders in their way like
there's not really a border in my way
I'm just lazy she's talking about Saving
Private Ryan and how in China people
found it kind of strange to the notion
of saving one person by risking the
lives of six other people she relates
that to voting so kind of saying that
your vote doesn't matter
it's almost saying that you know one
life doesn't really matter me being
Cuban and you know my parents are from
becoming his country voting is not a
thing this world war two veteran had
never missed voting and on his deathbed
he votes yeah okay way to make me feel
bad watching these videos kind of made
me realize the contrast between how I
feel about voting and how a lot of other
people feel about voting I feel like the
voting process in America is actually
pretty simple vote because you have the
right to vote because you feel like it's
your civil liberty to and vote because
it's the right thing to do it's really
opened my mind lets me feel like an
apple
I got some thinking to do yeah I want
average assertive oh yeah coming in my
email that was easy